funny fanfic we are back at it like a
heart attack
rhyme [ __ ] hey what is going on YouTube
it's been a while since we did a funny
fat bit but let's talk about this
now one of the biggest struggles with my
weight loss has always been revolved
around food yes - nobody surprised I
love food now I want you to understand
something there's a lot of people out
there that say that they love food but I
think you really love food you
[ __ ] are all talk yeah you talk
to talk but you can't walk the what the
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ] that was
a second to run asaurus rex likes Ewok
what's up cuz
it's weird my relationship with my meals
I'm emotionally dependent on the [ __ ] I
never put my dick in a pie but you know
I once punched a baby in the stomach for
some sliced apples to tell you the truth
not only your life sliced apples but he
ate them like they was so delicious
babies always eat their food like it's
the most delicious thing they'd ever
eaten in their life you ever seen a
two-year-old eat a spaghetti noodle you
would think there was crack on that
[ __ ] I'm just saying people y'all don't
love food the way I love food for me
it's an emotional addiction yeah i'ma
say it again
y'all don't love food the way I love
food and I say that food is an emotional
addiction because the type of food that
I eat has a direct correlation for my
mood for the rest of the day this is
true because when I started improving my
dive into something that was more
healthy and acceptable I became the
biggest [ __ ] weight David had a
broccoli he's gonna be a [ __ ]
anything you say or can't say to me will
be used against you if you touch my bag
of Doritos you ever notice that every
time you try to do something better with
your diet somebody guys say something
stupid about what you eat them you know
how many grams of saturated fat that has
don't eat that this is better
this has rip 11/10 minute means why
don't you shut the [ __ ] up and let me be
mother [ __ ] you think I don't know
what's going on with my food by now
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm on a specific
diet plan I don't need you to tell me
about what I can and can't eat I already
know stop reminding me [ __ ] if I need
help I will ask you but until then
should I put my [ __ ] up always gotta hit
that [ __ ] and I don't want to be
reminded of let me tell you something
else
what if I reminded you that you were
ugly and nobody loved you see I didn't
mean that I just want a cheeseburger I
said to ask God why did you do this
you do this to us is it gonna be those
[ __ ] why would the best-tasting
food be so bad for your body what kind
of sick [ __ ] is that
Doritos should cure cancer a
filet-o-fish should improve your vision
I know what but should have larger
breasts and then larger penis are the
way around depending what but no
everything that tastes good gotta give
you cancer [ __ ] [ __ ] cancer and you know
before all this nutritional science [ __ ]
came out it used to just be the basic
[ __ ] pizza burgers soda chips and now
when you're eating supposedly healthy
food it's too much of this it's too much
of that [ __ ] be calm and you guys ever
realized that when you change your diet
and she's never really hungry you're
just craving foods that you want that
your body is addicted to it's been so
many years of training your body and
your palates of wanting high fats high
sugars and processed carbs that when you
don't get it you're stuck to get pissed
off why is this [ __ ] so huh you know I'm
a completely different man from who I
was last year but it doesn't change the
fact that this [ __ ] is still hard you
know I will tell you though they're
physically and emotionally I actually am
a lot better than I was but damn
sometimes you just want to [ __ ] eat a
cheeseburger okay hey what's going on
YouTube hope you like that video because
funny fat fish is bad but guess what I
got a quick promo oh yeah now the
promotion that I'm going to be talking
to you guys about today is fan duel what
fandoms gonna do is gonna get you money
why play [ __ ] for free when you can make
cash on that ass so what is FanDuel you
ask FanDuel has one day fantasy baseball
leagues for real money and immediate
cash and yes there are no season-long
commitments or upfront fees you could
earn up to a dollar or even a thousand
plus guys to limit my friends now if
y'all think this is wack check this out
this is a true story there is a dude
named Chris Prince who has a postal
worker and also an avid fantasy player
he won five hundred and thirty five
thousand dollars
doing what you ask playing FanDuel now
if you guys want to join or even peep
and check out to see what fan duel is
about make sure you click the big link
below and make sure you use the promo
code David so comedy why you ask because
vanduul is going to match up to $200 of
whatever you deposit yes $200 so once
again click that big league
use that promo code and if they use to
wonder bucks are gonna get messed $200
guess what vandal and Davis so gonna
break that [ __ ]
toejam all right funny fest fit I will
see you next time I know this funny
benefit was on a Friday we'll get some
but I had to switch it up I got really
busy but I will see y'all again and make
sure y'all FanDuel it out I think I know
booger in my nose throughout that whole
thing oops
you know revolt has always been um about
they ever eaten their life oh god Jackie
O's okay